il me revient de clôturer ce panel avant
de passer la parole à notre président
pour la clôture général vous dire un mot
sur la délinquance des mineurs lors de
lens de 1945 s'inscrivait dans un
contexte historique d'après guerre
est ce que la délinquance juvénile de
cette époque là à avoir quelque chose
avec la délinquance juvénile si on ose
dire d'aujourd'hui brice hortefeux
rappelé tout à l'heure dans son mot
d'introduction que s'il n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation globale significative la
délinquance des mineurs
il y à une augmentation par contre la
violence 1 et la gravité des infractions
commises par les faux savoir qu'à peu
près un crime ou délit sur cinq ont sur
six est le fait d'un mineur donc on ne
peut pas évidemment laisser cette
situation s'aggravait encore davantage
elle s'explique par le fait et vous le
savez tous que dans l'application réelle
devant les tribunaux pour enfants
les peines sont peu prononcée peu ou
prou voir peu ou prou exécuté ce qui
évidemment pour un mineur est perçu
comme un permis de continuer un permis
de récidiver il ya une telle
permissivité que vous voyez souvent des
mineurs arrivé devant les juridictions
pour enfants avec des casiers
judiciaires
10 20 30 et au delà condamnation sans
jamais un jour de véritables sanctions
qui est une signification pour le mineur
alors partant de ce2 ce constat nous
évidemment nous réagirons fortement si
comme et saleh a annoncé par madame
taubira mais également semble-t-il par
le président la république anh a fait un
engagement la suppression des tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs cette une
décision purement idéologique nous le
pensons qu'il faudra évidemment
dans ce cas-là rétablir les tribunaux
correctionnels pour mineurs mais nous
allons plus loin je serais assez bref et
synthétique
nous allons aller beaucoup plus loin
dans les propositions puisque nous
pensons qu'il va qu'il faudra en finir
avec cette double casquette du juge pour
enfants qui est à la fois juge de
l'assistance éducative et juste de la
délinquance des mineurs
pourquoi ne pas donner comme compétence
tout ce qui est l'assistance éducative à
un tribunal de la famille à juge de la
famille est réservé un juge non pas des
enfants parce que je pense que lui mots
ont leur symbole et c'est important
un juge des mineurs qui sera compétent
pour juger la délinquance des mineurs
comment voulez vous qu'avec cette double
casquette injuste pour enfants
aujourd'hui qui essayait tant et tant de
mesures éducatives qui ont échoué qui
tire lui-même les conséquences de ces
échecs pour pouvoir prononcer une
sanction c'est pratiquement humainement
impossibles demande est donc sain dont
ses fonctions l'assistance éducative les
conseils départementaux sous l'autorité
et le contrôle du tribunal pour la
famille et un tribunal pour mineurs qui
sera chargée de l'application de la loi
et de la sanction et il faudra dans le
même temps remplir l'engagement qui n'a
pas été tenue par l'actuelle majorité
c'est-à-dire de doubler les centres
éducatifs fermés et les établissements
pour mineurs est d'ailleurs l'idée de
scission de cette fonction de jeu les
enfants
elle avait même été je préside en
souvenez évoqué est proposé en 1998 par
jean pierre chevènement qui avait je
peux pas vous en souvenez qui avait
effectivement dit cette double
compétence à laquelle il peut être utile
de mettre fin présente un inconvénient
de principe elle contribue à brouiller
l'image du jeune enfant tant aux juges
de la pathologie familial proche de
l'assistance sociale
tantôt juge répressif c'est de cela dont
il faut sortir
voilà je ne serai pas plus long et je
voudrais maintenant céder la parole à
notre président